let's talk about the playoffs big
picture right now as it relates to
legacies and this is our question of the
day i'm going to put it out on twitter
here during the first break whose legacy
will benefit the most from emerging from
the next 11 postseason games with a
super bowl ring and it can be anybody it
can be a player it can be a coach it
could be a gm it can be an owner it can
be anyone peter who who is the first
name that comes to mind for you as
someone whose legacy benefits the most
from running the table and winning it
all
first name for me mike is andy reid um
because obviously andy reid got his
eagles to a super bowl one time
and they didn't beat the patriots that
time in jacksonville and now he's got
probably the best team he's had
certainly the best team he's had in
kansas city and the team with the best
chance
you know to run the table in kansas city
but the more i thought of that the more
i said look andy reed is going to coach
several more years i would assume he's
showing no signs you know as a 60 61
year old guy whatever he is he's showing
no signs of of wanting to retire he's
got this quarterback that he's dreamed
of
so he's going to coach a while and
that's why in my opinion the more i
thought about this the more i thought
it's not andy reid
it's philip rivers
because now as philip rivers
finishes his 15th season in the nfl
you just don't know which direction the
future is going to go for a guy like
philip rivers is he ever going to be
in the playoffs again is he ever going
to have a team as good as this a defense
as good as this
and is he ever going to have a path as
difficult as this
i mean imagine if philip rivers does get
to the super bowl philip rivers has to
go through baltimore maybe the toughest
defense in football
and then you know pick a path
new england the five-time super bowl
champions with tom brady refusing to say
die and then
maybe coming back to kansas city where
finally the chargers got off the schneid
during the regular season but now
having to finally say hey look i can win
a super bowl just like my 2004 draft
mates ben roethlisberger and eli manning
and i deserve to win a super bowl and i
think deep down that's what phillip
rivers thinks and look at this stage of
his career you just don't know how many
more chances you're going to get at this
stage of his tenure
i think andy reid's got several chances
left
yeah and i agree with you completely and
if he's even considering when he would
walk away from the nfl i think the
answer is whenever patrick mahomes does
because mahomes is special enough what
we've seen from him this isn't just one
guy who shows up and hey he's the he's
the best quarterback from the mold we're
used to he's a guy who is a different
mold altogether he has created in one
season a career's worth of highlights
and he's just getting started and if
mahomes would win a super bowl think
about this peter because we've been
trying to draw parallels to past
quarterbacks who who had huge impacts
right away dan marino in 84 although he
did play 10 11 games in 83 so it's not
quite the same kurt warner in 99 who
really wasn't you know a young player
he'd been around for five years but he
came out of nowhere in 99 won the nfl
mvp won the super bowl mvp it's kind of
a a cross between mourinho and warner if
mahomes could do it and the bottom line
is it's mahomes it's it's a new breed
it's a new era where a guy comes in
first year as a starter second year in
the nfl wins the regular season mvp
award best player in the sport and
cashes in with an nfl
super bowl
mvp trophy because chances are that's
who the mvp would be if the chiefs would
win it all that we've never seen that
before and we may never see that again
mike you know i'll never forget being at
the super bowl in palo alto uh when joe
montana and dan marino played in the
game and the entire theme was after the
49ers won this game the entire theme was
hey dan marino don't worry about it kid
you're gonna get here five more times
you know your your day is coming and he
never got there again
so as much as i want to say that andy
reed and patrick mahomes are going to
have a few more chances you just really
don't know
we are at the start of a 12 team
tournament and some of the craziest
things have happened in this 12 team
tournament but i will say this more
recently in this 12 team tournament
being the higher seed has been a huge
advantage you know you really have to go
back to sort of almost to the giants
days
you know in 2007 and 11 to find a lesser
team in the regular season
uh you know who
that that really
uh
took a great trip through the playoffs
and ended up winning the super bowl now
it has been the province lately of the
very high seeds
that's what to me holds the chiefs
promised so much this year because
they're going to be playing at home and
mike i can tell you
last night i went out with an nbc crew
we went out around town and we talked to
a lot of fans last night i went to a
tattoo parlor last night and talked to a
guy who's done more than 20 patrick
mahomes tattoos on people one of which a
full face was an eight-hour job on a
woman
and so i just
you're sensing this thing around this
town like no matter what team they've
had in the past you have to go all the
way back to lenny dawson and hank stram
for a city
uh in in a civic way to be as excited as
this city is and so i mentioned that
because i think their home field edge
here is going to be gigantic i've never
been in a tattoo parlor
just merely being there does does it
create a temptation to get a tattoo
yes i have to tell you we're there about
10 o'clock last night
and i said to marissa boyajian the
producer i said if you get one i'll get
one
and
okay so i was lying
okay i was lying i i don't i had i was
not gonna get one i have no idea i have
no desire to put ink on my skin but
you know i know everybody else does it
now me and you are the last two holdouts
on planet earth by the way
what would you get well i owe you would
you get an o.u bobcats i mean what would
it be if you would get one no i would
not get an ou bobcat i don't i think i
would get ann
you know my wife's name i'd get it i'd
get it right across here you know i i
think i think it would be lovely i'd get
the mike tyson
oh boy i think we may have some folks in
graphics who can give you at least a
glimpse of what that would look like i
have a feeling we'll be seeing that at
some point over the next couple of hours
another name that that uh that we should
consider a guy who i assume has his
likeness
somewhere on the body of various eagles
fans the guy who was the super bowl mvp
last year and you talked about the
benefit of being the one seed and how
the one seeds have been cashing in in
recent years even though there was a
time whereas a 50 50 proposition that
the one seed would even make it out of
the divisional round the eagles and nick
foles last year the one seed this year
the sixth seed this year they have to
try to do what the steelers did in o5
what the packers did in 2010
nick if the eagles would do this again
when you think about the teams they'd
have to play just to even get there you
have to beat the bears in chicago you
have to beat the new the saints in new
orleans then you have to maybe play the
rams or you'd have to play the seahawks
of the cowboys this would not be an easy
run but my god if nick foles coming off
the bench in december for the second
straight year could lead the eagles to
the top of the mountain especially as
the sixth seed this year i somebody
asked me the question yesterday if that
would put him in the hall of fame that
accomplishment in and of itself and i
doubt that it would but my god it would
make a hell of an argument
well more importantly for now
mike i was on the phone with an nfl head
coach yesterday
and he asked me this question he said
just suppose
if the philadelphia eagles run the table
what do the eagles do then with nick
foles and carson wentz
and it's very easy to knee jerk say
you can only keep one quarterback
and you've got to go with wence you know
he's the long-term best bet it's very
easy to say that
but mike i don't know if you'd say that
anymore
i don't know how you could say that
anymore and so i turn it on you
if this happens and i mean it's a
5 chance 10 whatever it is
but if that happens
you're howie roseman you're the general
manager of the philadelphia eagles
what do you do on the morning you wake
up after winning the second straight
super bowl with nick foles
oh if if you win a second straight super
bowl with nick foles and he's the mvp
for the second straight year and that
will have meant you you won three must
win regular season games and then four
post season games with nick falls i i'd
say you sign nick foles long term you
trade carson wentz you get what you can
and you go all in with nick foles for
the rest of his career because he will
have proven it he will have earned it
and i know it's going to be difficult to
do because of everything they gave up to
get once but the thing that we have
realized in recent weeks carson wentz is
a better quarterback but the eagles are
a better team when he plays and that's
even before
he wins four postseason games you throw
four postseason wins on top of it and i
think it's a no-brainer for me peter the
decision becomes difficult if they beat
the bears this weekend and they keep it
close with the saints because they got
blown out when wentz played 48 to 7. if
they keep it within 10 points of the
saints you at least have to have the
conversation they beat for me if they
beat the saints
that's the point where you have to
seriously consider falls as your future
you win the super bowl i think it's a
no-brainer
i think you're right mike and it's one
of those questions that it's probably
best not to consider too hard right now
because it could drive you crazy you'd
go spinning into orbit
but i i would i would just make one
point
and i was making this point to a friend
of mine who's a huge eagles fan this
week
and he said
don't we have to keep fools
and i said i just want you to remember
one thing
remember
your team
14 months ago
i was at the link on a monday night uh
either october early november
eagles washington
and carson wentz just lit up the night
sky
with beautiful throws great
pocket presents
uh knowing when to hold them when to
fold them when to when to run when to
stay
um i just thought that
this guy is going to compete for the mvp
this year
um and he did and until that fateful
afternoon at the la coliseum who knows
what would have happened brady probably
would have won
but that would have been a heck of a run
by by carson wentz and i believe this
year
people are judging carson wentz on the
wrong
set uh of criteria and people are
judging him based on what they saw last
year to me you come back from tearing
two neat knee ligaments in nine and a
half months when the doctor said
originally this a nine to 12 month
process and you come back after nine and
a half months you look fine but
something wasn't fine this year
and so that's why if i am an eagles fan
if i'm howie rosen if i'm doug peterson
i am remembering the days of november
2017.
not november 2018.
we got to run but i just got to make a
quick point here for me i'm thinking
about december of 2017 and december of
2018 both months
carson wentz isn't able to play and now
we have this back problem that
apparently traces back to earlier days
of football and back problems don't get
better they only get worse and i would
be concerned about wences availability
for a full season moving forward if
foles isn't there to come in and save
the day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports